all right there is this fair bit of news
the world we lived in where we thought a
cappella was actually lame is not true
it's not the real world because
apparently in the real world a cappella
can be pretty cool
[Music]
pitch-perfect something I am not so
[ __ ] perfect stars Anna Kendrick she's
the standoffish girl on campus I love
that picture of Anna Kendrick I will use
that picture in any video I mentioned
Anna Kendrick and why because that's why
that is why adds a good picture but
she's a standoffish girl on campus she
likes remix in music she has no interest
in any acapella group but she ends up
joining this acapella group and it turns
out she's really good at and this
acapella group is like really old-school
they play these boring ass songs sounds
great but they're all in harmony but
they play that music that you ever go
into a retail store and you're like this
music is perfectly suitable for all ages
and it's boring as [ __ ] and every
employee there wants to kill themselves
yeah they play that music but now Anna
Kendrick's on the scene so things are
about to get fun no am i the target
demographic for this movie not really No
then again if you see my reviews I end
up enjoying those movies that are based
around music I have a soft spot for
music any movie that gets me to tap my
foot during the music it automatically
gets points with me maybe I'm the target
demographic for this movie but the point
is I don't watch Glee so long story
short if you love Glee you're gonna love
this movie however if you don't you
might actually like this movie because
the movies pretty fun and it has
competition their main competition in
this movie are these guys called the
troublemakers and they're complete
douche bags their leader at least as a
douche bag but they're really good
they're acapella songs always kick-ass
the actors are really good I mean you
have Anna Kendrick in this movie and she
is a really good actress you could argue
that this movie is pretty much a step up
movie with acapella I mean you have this
one person that comes to this school
that has this thing you know is not
dancing it's acapella and they join this
group and they're absurdly good at it so
they enter a competition it's pretty
much a step up movie however it has
better writing better actors and
actually it has jokes in it some jokes
are really funny some jokes fall fly but
the point is it makes an attempt at
being really likable Anna Kendrick kind
of has this romance going on with this
dude and sometimes you're like you did
chick you're a bag of drama rocks right
there you need to stop being like that
she has these really thick walls up she
doesn't let people in I imagine cracking
through the Anna Kendrick walls would
build a really strong relationship and
be worth it in the long run however
[ __ ] a cappella chick from pitch
perfect yeah cuz the quick and easy path
is just awesome I never claimed to be a
role model just a realist although I
think a role model
should be a realist so there is the
paradox I will say it the formula of the
movies pretty predictable you know
exactly how the movies gonna go when the
movie starts however this movies not
going for an Oscar it's there to be fun
and show some really good acapella in
the movie end up tapping your foot you
like the music you actually like the
characters and you walk out going yeah
that was a pretty good time I will say
pitch-perfect is a good time no alcohol
required so what is your favorite
musical score from any movie I think
that's a good question for a movie based
on acapella in which I have no other
question for you whatever your favorite
musical score is comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]